what if I told you the biggest Monopoly
we have in America today isn't Google
isn't Apple isn't Facebook isn't Amazon
but it's in our K-12 schools and
universities and I have data to prove it
and on top of that I'm gonna make an
argument to you today why you ought to
consider having your kids leave Public
Schools as soon as possible and by the
way before you say how could you say
something like that Patrick you're a
byproduct of a public school I'm a
byproduct of a public school how could
you say something like that you're
assuming that today's public school is
the same as the public school you and I
went to a lot has changed and last but
not least I'm going to show you two
numbers the cost of sending your kids to
a private school versus a public school
taxes we pay for and you'll be able to
decide and see that private school is
actually cheaper than sending our kids
to public school if we allowed it to the
free market to decide so let's get right
into it
foreign
I want to make my argument you may like
it you may not like it but if you do get
value from this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel let's
get right into it let's look at some
stats of private schools versus public
schools in America we have roughly 32
461 private schools 5.72 million
students are in private schools in
America which is roughly 10.1 percent of
all students by the way 643
000 of the 5.72 million is in California
alone if you were wondering which
private schools are leading the most at
the top is Catholic schools 38.8 percent
of them and the least popular is Islam
0.8 percent these private schools
combined have 441 496 full-time teachers
average private school size in America
is only 176 students some of you guys
may be thinking it's a thousand it's two
thousand nope that's public most private
schools are very small and the total
dollar amount it takes to operate these
32 461 schools is roughly 87.5 billion
dollars per year they get this through
raising money and through getting
tuition that's how they do they don't
get of money from the government hence
it's a private school so now let's take
a look at Public Schools we have 97 568
different Public Schools a total of 50.6
million students that are enrolled the
average class of a public school is 519
students remember compared to 176
students and their funding is roughly
640 billion dollars that you and I paid
for once again 640 billion dollars that
uni pay for now on the other hand when
it comes down to Public Schools public
schools have 3.2 million full-time
teachers so if you were to kind of break
down the map in public school for every
one teacher There are 16 students and in
private for every one teacher there are
12 students so you get slightly more
attention per student in private than in
public so now let's look at which states
lead the way in enrollments in America
I'll give you the top five Public School
states in America number one is
California 6.86 Million number two is
Texas 5.84 Million number three is Ford
at 3.38 million New York is four
Illinois is five but here's an
interesting stat from 1990 till today
which school has increased enrollment
the most look at the numbers Texas has
increased 60.6 percent Florida's
increased 52.9 percent California is not
even half of those two numbers at 26.7
Illinois is at 8.8 and New York is
barely grown since 1990 that's 30 plus
years ago only 3.9 percent so now let's
look at lost let's look at cost if you
send your kids to private school or if
we would have done public school with
all the taxes we're paying per student
the average cost for a private school in
America according to educationdata.org
is 12 350 dollars per year and if you
want to know what the high is in
Connecticut is 24 000 and Wisconsin is
thirty five hundred but on average is 12
350 okay for private school if you were
to break down the Public Funding the
money you and I paying taxes 640 billion
dollars for 50.6 million students now we
send these taxes to how much we pay per
student here's what the numbers would
look like twelve thousand six hundred
and forty eight dollars so now again
twelve thousand three fifty private
school 12648 public school less private
more for public so the question you
gotta ask is the following I don't have
a problem paying more for public because
it's better is it where you're like no
public sucks
my kids I don't even know what they're
gonna eat the teaching all this other
stuff well then this is why you ought to
consider sending your kids to private
school that's what we're having this
conversation so now let's look at a
couple different things when it comes
down to school and what things we should
be concerned about these are 10 or 11
things they have here number one parents
not being involved enough when you look
at statistics of how kids do parents
involvement in school is just as
important if not more important than the
actual school kids go to a vice recently
did a research on this and a guy who's
Asian talks about why so many Asians do
so well in school and he's trying to
explain to them and everybody's
interrupting him he says look if you
want to know why kids do so well in
Asian families is because parents
typically stay together they have higher
expectations of kids going to school and
they're involved they want to know how
you're doing in homework they're there
you have to give a lot of credence to
that so number one the reason why kids
don't do well in public schools parents
are not involved number two classes are
overcrowded we already looked at the
stats earlier on what it looks like for
Public School 16-1 versus private school
12-1 the more crowded it is the less
attention teacher is going to put into
your student number three number three
is affordability can the average person
afford to send their kids to school
private school and pay that twelve
thousand three hundred fifty dollars
most of you could think is forty
thousand or fifty thousand but twelve
thousand three hundred fifty to most
that's still a lot of money but I'm
telling you right now if you're watching
this and you're making 75 grand a year
you're making a hundred thousand dollars
a year you're making a hundred fifty
thousand dollars into you Pat that's a
lot of money for me to send my three
kids to private school I am telling you
based on some of the things we'll talk
about find a way to make that extra
money with a side hustle to send your
kids to private school I'm not telling
you finance your house I'm not telling
you take all your savings out of your
401k I'm not telling you to do all that
other stuff I'm telling you find a
secondary income to be able to fund
private schools because public schools
are not what they once used to be number
four Public Schools take a long time to
adapt and adjust to the Innovation
that's taking place today so stamp
technology all of that you're way behind
the eight ball private schools because
there's pressure from parent parents who
are giving money to the private school
they can say why are we not making
investments into this why are we not
doing that why are we not doing this and
the people running the school have to
listen to the parents because you're
paying them money remember anything
that's free is usually cheap and you
have no voice to say anything to them
anything you pay for that service you
can also expect a higher experience and
service if you're paying for it not
telling you we're living in a perfect
world but there's more ability to be
able to impose and ask when you're
paying for something then just sending
them to a public school Point number
five school safety a lot of parents
nowadays if you're going to public
school parents are concerned are my kids
safe do schools have the funding to pay
for the safety they provide for you and
I well we don't have the money the
state's not giving us this the state's
not giving us that versus in a private
school parents can meet and say hey what
are we doing to make it safer well
here's what we're doing you got to come
through here when you're dropping them
off you got to do this you got to do
that that is another thing that a lot of
parents are thinking about not telling
you private schools are more safe than
public school but generally private
schools are safer than pop schools so
Point number six may be number one on a
lot of parents lists which is curriculum
and the woke mob coming after their kids
they want to take their kids out of
public schools to put them in private
schools or even consider homeschooling I
want to give you some stats here and you
make a decision for yourself do you
remember at the beginning of the video
what's the first thing I said when we
started the video I'm going to share
with you the biggest Monopoly in America
and it's not Apple Google Facebook
Amazon remember that and I said is in
public schools let me give you some
stats in Hollywood what percentage of
actors in Hollywood do you think are
Democrats versus Republicans what do you
think it is the answer is 90 are
Democrats 10 percent are Republicans and
generally the 10 that are Republicans
they're very quiet now let's break it
down on teachers in public schools
here's the data this is written about in
an article by Washington Post by a
research conducted of verdant Labs using
political contribution data on the
Democrat Republican divide based on job
type English teachers out of 100 English
teachers in public schools 97 are
Democrats three percent of Republicans
Health teachers 99 of all public school
health teachers are Democrats one
percent Republicans math and science is
the only one that's slightly fairer 87
percent are Democrats 13 are Republicans
now if you're watching this and you're a
Democrat what do you say wow this is
awesome I think what you need to ask
yourself is why are you a Democrat maybe
because all your teachers were Democrats
and you eventually got baptized because
there was no debate what I like is
debate I'm a public school kid this guy
right here I don't like when people say
look at what Facebook is a monopoly they
got to break them apart they gotta break
apart Apple and Google and Amazon this
is not fair it's abuse this is the
ultimate Monopoly to the same people so
concerned about Apple Facebook why don't
we break you apart why don't we make
this even 50 50. why don't we make it 50
50. would you be okay with that
specifically if this is shared with a
democratic teacher I'm sure you're
losing your mind right now watching this
getting ready to type and say how much
of a fool I am for giving you these
stats I'm okay with that I have what you
call thick skin is what what I have
because I like debate I don't like the
echo chamber I spend a little bit more
time on this one here because we have a
monopoly and if you as a parent are okay
with this send your kids to public
school but if you as a parent now know
about this data and you're still sending
your kids to public school and not
making that additional money to have
that discourse with your kids and don't
be upset that you lose your kids when
they turn 18 and they say Mom Dad you
have no clue what you're talking about
it's your fault Mommy and Daddy not the
teacher's fault you have a choice to
work a little harder make a little bit
more money find that additional 12 13
000 a year maybe twenty thousand dollars
where you're living and send your kids
to private school so they don't get
brainwashed this is where you get to
pick and choose what school for your
kids to go to that learn the right
values and principles I'm not talking
about being perfect by the way even at
private schools it's generally 50 50
with Republicans and Democrats my kids
go to private schools a lot of their
teachers are Democrats this doesn't mean
it's guaranteed that they're 90
Republicans not at all the reason why I
like private schools because it's pretty
much 50 50 in private schools but in
public public schools for law Monopoly
anyways that's Point number six number
seven which is going to seem common
sense to you but it's going to trigger
certain people you ready I believe great
teachers are underpaid not teachers I
believe great teachers are underpaid and
I believe Bad Teachers should be fired
not yesterday not a year ago the day
they got hired bad teachers need to be
fired there are certain people that
shouldn't be teachers and there's many
of them right now that are still working
because those districts are desperate
for teachers and they're desperately
hiring bad quality teachers fireworks a
lot of parents this is something they
think about and it is a concern on
almost every list you look at from the
left the right the middle it doesn't
matter there's a lot of bad teachers out
there there are a lot of underpaid great
teachers out there so number eight is
mental health and I want to talk to you
from a parent standpoint I'm a parent
I'm a father of four kids 11 year old
today 9 6 and a 19 month old and there's
a lot of different things that kids are
dealing with today that is different
than what I dealt when I was a kid I
didn't have Facebook Twitter Instagram
all these pressure even Chad gbt we
didn't have any of these stuff right
when I was a kid so the challenges are
different however I think in many cases
sometimes teachers also don't know how
to handle this not saying teachers are
perfect but they don't know how to
handle this I'll give it to you from my
own personal experience my kid my oldest
son goes to school and a teacher really
has a hard time with this guy so the
first thing says oh he can't pay
attention yeah okay you call it what the
whole ADHD thing okay he can't pay
attention he's got to go see this
counsel of this therapist so I don't
know where they're going but because I'm
a curious guy I'm following their you
know their protocols so we go and I'm
just waiting for the teacher to
prescribe some medication there you go
we sit there and we'll go oh yeah oh
okay cool we'd like to do a test yeah
well I just want to see you guys got a
camera what you do to my son I just got
to say I don't have to be in there yeah
yeah oh okay yeah yeah okay no problem
great and then yeah we think your kid
needs to take such and such I said
really yes and I don't think so I think
my kid has what I have it's called being
creative it's called being a young boy
and it's called you're all over the
place God knows how many times I moved
as a kid I've moved so many times in
Iran When The War was happening I moved
to Germany refugee camp not learning
German and being bullied on not speaking
German and looking Middle Eastern in
Germany they don't like Middle Easterns
if you go there and have to learn how to
make friends and I came to the states
and I got to learn another language and
we're moving from this from that from
this parents divorce trust me life was
very annoying for a long time as a kid
so I'm dealing with stuff and I'm
handling stuff on my own too often in
these types of cases teachers are not
properly trained on how to handle these
types of kids they automatically put
them in a box and then we find out 33
years later that kid was a genius we
find out 42 years later when we're using
a technology like oh my god oh remember
that one kid in fifth grade that we
thought was so freaking weird his name
was Elon is this the same Elon Musk let
me go back wow he was in our class that
was our student what a big mistake on
mine I thought this kid was a troubled
kid no he just wired in a different way
than you are so sometimes parents like I
watch very closely with how my teachers
sell me who my kids are and when I'm in
all these parentage your conference that
they do and I'm involved I'm trying to
see what they say about my kid and my
wife will always say babe so what do you
think about my kid you know and I'll
just sit there and I listen to him I
won't say anything but if I notice
there's not an understanding about the
kid I'll take that moment and I'll say
hey one thing about my son you I don't
know he's like me here's how I was okay
cool this is what works with them if you
need us let us know the more you
communicate the better we'll be able to
work together as a team we're here to
support you but please understand our
son is like Papa no problem great guess
what point number one was what parents
not being involved this is the part of
what parents got to be more involved
which kind of helps when kids are going
through the challenges that they're
going through in these types of
situations because nobody was involved
with me and I was pretty alone I was
like man I don't know who to talk I
thought it was really weird you realize
it took me 25 years to realize I was
weird but it's good that I was weird and
I'm okay with it but at the time when
everyone's calling you weird you really
think you're weird and you have problems
does that make sense anyways if it does
it does if it doesn't trust me it makes
sense to five to ten percent of people
that are watching this so this next one
many parents May relate to and some of
you guys will fully disagree with this
one too to me it's when we took prayer
out of school and got out of school that
was a problem in my eyes let me explain
myself and you can say I disagree or I
agree do you know what year it was when
we took prayers out of school it was
1962. do you know why it was a case
Engel versus vital and the simple prayer
they took out of school do you know what
the prayer was this is what the prayer
was almighty God we acknowledge our
dependence upon thee and we beg thy
blessings upon us our parents our
teachers and our country there's no
Jesus mentioned there's nothing
mentioned this prayer is a prayer of
what I am grateful for the blessings my
parents my teachers and my country it's
actually a good prayer for kids to have
but we took it up now for some of you
that love having these debates about God
exists God doesn't exist Faith this
faith that let me just give you my case
I believe whether this thing is right or
wrong when the kid becomes an adult he's
gonna go through his own Journey I'll
figure not what God is real or it's not
that's his journey but when the kid is
younger and he doesn't share all his
fears and anxieties with his parents
isn't it better if he believes in a God
or Spirit that's bigger than him that he
can talk to him at any time and he's got
his back what do you think don't you
think that helps that kid out a little
bit more on how to cope with these
things while he's 11 years old while
he's 14 years old I don't know maybe I'm
wrong and by the way let me tell you the
crazy story I was an atheist for 25
years myself I'm telling you this myself
this much of belief that there is Faith
even when I was an atheist I would pray
to a god I didn't believe existed
because others told me try praying and I
was my only out okay and as an adult
it's a completely different story
anyways last point we took prayer out I
think it was also problematic and I
think we could solve a lot of different
things if kids can do a simple prayer as
almighty God we acknowledge our
dependence upon thee and we beg thy
blessings upon us our parents our
teachers and our country I think I can
help the kids out a little bit more
dealing with certain challenges that
they're dealing with today my final
thoughts on the wrap up I think life is
all about risks who you marry risky you
don't know if it's going to work out
you're not going to know for decades
maybe it doesn't work out but it was
great at first having a job risky
starting a business risky Living in
America risky driving on the freeway
risky because others are on their phones
there is risk involved but there's a lot
of risk today with you sending your kids
to public school and sending your kids
to colleges that you know nothing about
I had a friend of mine who sent his
daughter to a school in Illinois his
daughter and him were like this he says
I spent two hundred thousand dollars
sending my kids to this one school every
year she liked me less and every year
she was more bitter to me and rather
than coming back home she said I don't
want to come back and be around you I
cannot believe you're a capitalist and
you're this I used to respect you all
you care about is money the university
the father sent two hundred thousand
dollars to created this layer of
division between him and his daughter
that him and the two of them were even
like close like you wouldn't believe
it's a risk that's all I'm telling you
you decide whether you're comfortable
with this risk or not if you can figure
out a way to make more money to send
your kids to A Better Private School I
highly recommend you start doing some
research anyways if you got value from
the video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel I got another
video I want you to watch 15 things they
don't teach in school if you've not
watched it click here to watch it take
care everybody bye bye
foreign
[Music]